depuis 45 ans patrick et isabelle
balkany sont connus des français pour
être les visages emblématiques de la
ville de levallois-perret en région
parisienne une ville que patrick balkany
accompagné d'isabelle a dirigé pendant
trente ans le 6 mars 2020 le couple est
démis de ses mandats municipaux ils sont
condamnés par la cour d'appel qui les
accuse de blanchiment de fraude fiscale
pour avoir dissimulé une partie de leur
patrimoine immobilier
une affaire très complexe aux nombreux
rebondissements le 13 septembre 2019
patrick balkany est sanctionné par une
peine de quatre ans de prison ferme est
envoyé directement derrière les barreaux
quant à isabelle elle est condamnée à
trois ans de prison ferme mais sans
mandat de dépôt
le 12 février 2020 patrick balkany sort
prison en raison de son état de santé
qui se dégrade incompatible avec une
incarcération depuis les dénouement
judiciaire s'enchaînent pour le couple
jusqu'à aujourd'hui où l'on a appris
qu'ils allaient être placées sous
bracelet électronique
sa carrière sa vie personnelle c'est à
faire ce soir isabelle balkany est avec
nous et brisent le silence dans les pmp
merci isabelle balkany d'être avec nous
je le dis aux téléspectateurs un voile
acquis qu'ils le sachent que je suis pas
hypocrite
isabelle balkany on se connaît très bien
on va passer matière je veux pas
raconter d'histoires voilà ce qu'on a
mangé bien on se connaît depuis des
années voilà où on s'apprécie beaucoup
et après bien sûr voilà il ya plein de
choses voilà qui nous ont séparés mais
on est a toujours gardé contact voilà je
le dis je veux pas être dans
l'hypocrisie avec les téléspectateurs
voilà c'est aussi pour ça qu'elle est la
soie c'est vrai qu'on se connaît très
bien je connais très bien son fils
également qui est un voilà donc vraiment
voilà donc je préfère le dire aux
téléspectateurs au moins que ce soit
clair
au moins voilà qui disent pas voilà oui
voilà siricu un jour ou un truc comme ça
voilà comme ça c'est clair merci
isabelle en tout cas y'a qu'ça ce soit
surtout de la bière et de répondre à
toutes les questions parce que c'est
vrai que il y en a plein bien sûr ici
tous les autres rapports benjamin je
crois que vous ne connaissez personne
autour de la table
ils sont pleins de questions à vous
poser moi aussi j'ai déjà rencontré et
c'est vrai qu'il n'avait jamais vu ce
très beau garçon insulaire
oui hélas très beau gazon il est très
bonne mais c'est vrai qu'il est animé
vous aussi merci en tout cas isabelle
balkany d'être là je le redis c'est
évidemment une vie personnelle et
politique très riche
les balkany c'est vrai que vous mine de
rien vous fasciner alors je vais vous
laisser poser plein de questions à
isabelle moi aussi j'en poserait pouvant
poser également sur les réseaux sociaux
vous avez rencontré patrick balkany en
75 sur cette rencontre il se dit
beaucoup de choses certains parlent
d'une soirée littéraire d'autres d'un
match de boxe
ce que j'aimerais qu'on vienne à toute
l'histoire met donc ça s'est déroulé
comme on fait alors notre première
rencontre c'est tout simplement un match
de boxe effectivement ou comme j'aime la
boxe
j'avais demandé à des copains de
m'emmener c'était mon agent on a un bon
match faut bien le reconnaître
oui oui voyez je connais rien au
football un excusez moi je déteste ça
mais alors la boxe j'adore voilà et donc
assis à côté de moi un autre copain du
copain patrick et on s'est mariés trois
mois après exactement
déjà deux ans plus tard en 70 c'est déjà
votre première aventure politique à deux
ça auxerre dans l'yonne quand patrick
balkany se présente aux élections
législatives on va voir des images ça
n'était pas du tout mon mon métier
oui mon métier c'est la base comment
d'abord commencé par faire 2 en droit
vous savez à l'époque on était majeure a
21 ans et on obéissait son père et comme
j'ai passé mon bac à 16 ans mon père a
voulu que choisit droit j'ai calé sur le
droit constitutionnel je viens d'arriver
donc au bout de deux ans je suis partie
d'assas et je suis allé faire de la
sémantique à nanterre et j'ai été
stagiaire dans un journal magique qui
s'appelle combat ainsi que mon oncle
quinze maisons qu'elle avait racheté à
albert camus c'était le premier journal
de là à d'ailleurs son slogan c'était de
la résistance dès le premier journal de
la résistance de la résistance à la
révolution dirigée
par philippe tesson avec des
c'était un journal pas d'actu mais
d'opinion il y avait jean paul sartre on
va voir les merlus signer pour une
gamine de 16 ans est extraordinaire j'ai
vu des hommes ou deux femmes à l'époque
d'une intelligence manager j'étais
fasciné et ensuite j'ai été débauché
l'année de mes 21 ans juste avant
d'avoir 21 ans par maurice hiégel et
lucien morisse que j'avais rencontré qui
m'ont demandé de devenir directeur de la
communication d'europe 1 l'homme et
c'est vrai que l'actuel actu aujourd'hui
des médias fait que je suis très
heureuse si c'est il se réalise que
quelqu'un d'autre va ranimer cette
station et la station de mon coeur je
n'ai jamais pu a tellement sur le coup
on vous savez là où l'europe ont épluché
cavaliers alors juste isabelle après
toutes ces années d'amour vous êtes
toujours aussi amoureux tous les deux
puisque pour la saint-valentin patrick
balkany vous a fait une petite surprise
sur les panneaux de la ville de
levallois perret regardez
voilà comment ils n'ont pris les
habitants de levallois ils sont habitués
parce que figurez-vous que à levallois
pendant 35 ans je me suis occupé de ce
qui étaient mes compétences c'est-à-dire
la com de la ville la communication et
des jeunes de la ville et du département
des écoliers des collégiens et des rats
et j'ai eu l'idée il ya plus d'une
dizaine d'années je me rappelle même
plus quand puisqu'on avait ces panneaux
électroniques
le jour de la saint-valentin de les
ouvrir à tous les levalloisiens et çà et
là maintenant voilà alors donc et pour
tout vous dire et je les écris dans mon
tweet meilleur ce n'est pas patrick qui
me la fait pas d'accord patrick la
veille avait fait un post facebook en
mettant bonne fête à toutes les
valentins et bien sûr à isa et il avait
partagé la fameuse chanson de notre
vieux pote notre frère johnny je t'aime
et du coup c'est un nouvel oisiens qui
le lendemain a voulu faire un message
pour sa femme et qui du coup on avait
fait 1 pour patrick et qui a d'ailleurs
demandé à sa femme parce qu'ils ont un
panneau juste en match chez eux
d'attendre une demi heure dans un froid
glacial pour photographier le panneau
pour tout vous dire nous étions à le
vélo
nous étions allés au marché nous on n'a
pas vu le message et c'est seul
valoisien qui l'a publiée et après
évidemment j'ai embrayé
on va revenir sur tout ce qu'on appelle
la sphère balkany parce que ça dure
depuis des années et des années
ah oui alors est ce que gilles verdez au
petit résumé la faire parce qu'on sait
plus en fait oui c'est une affaire qui
s'est effectivement étiré et qui a donné
lieu récemment à un procès pour fraude
fiscale normalement on vous reprocher
d'avoir dissimulé de l'argent en suisse
notamment et d'avoir échappé au fisc
donc il ya une condamnation pour
l'aspect fraude fiscale en septembre
2019 quatre ans de prison ferme 10 ans
d'inégibilité
et puis il ya eu aussi une relaxe sur
des affaires de blanchiment et de
corruption
voilà et là maintenant on parle de
pourvoi en cassation
donc moi ma question madame elle est
simple il ya un faisceau d'affaires
comment vous vivez ça est ce qu'un jour
vous pensez qu'on verra le bout de ses
affaires parce que je signale simplement
que votre mari a été placé en janvier en
garde à vue pour une nouvelle affaire
qui concernerait un endroit qui auraient
été loués vos proches ont été entendus
ça ne s'arrête pas à madame les affaires
avec vous alors écoutez cher monsieur je
voudrais d'abord vous remercie de la
manière dont vous allez présenter les
choses parce que il ya évidemment des
choses qui me tiennent à coeur et que je
souhaite dire premièrement je souhaite
dire que effectivement la condamnation
que nous n'avons eu nous la méritons
tout simplement parce que effectivement
nous avons caché au fisc du patrimoine
familial
alors pour mon mari un père déporté un
père qui est venu en france nous sommes
des enfants d'immigrés tous les deux
patrick son père est venu en france il a
fait de la résistance il a été dénoncé
s'est retrouvé à auschwitz il en est
sorti parce qu'il a été dénoncé comme
résistant et pas comme juif très bien et
bien après quand il a gagné beaucoup
d'argent
il a souhaité vous savez comme disaient
nos grands mères maintenant je suis une
grand mère je peux venir savez les
choses vont dire que je suis une bonne
humeur
bon eh bien il a souhaité ne pas mettre
tous ses oeufs dans le même panier
voilà quant à moi pareil on vient de
tunisie
nous sommes juifs et mon père aussi a
souhaité d'une part mon père a souhaité
m mais ce n'est pas tellement mon père
c'est surtout à la mort de mon père au
décès de mon père mon frère et ma soeur
aînée malheureusement mon très fortement
les et comme a pu s'en rendre compte
le juge van ruymbeke qui est aller les
interroger et pour ne pas que ça se voit
à si je puis dire
ils sont émigrés vers la suisse et puis
à un moment donné où j'étais en
faiblesse dans ma vie parce que vous
savez je viens d'amour en 1 conques 3
incroyable avec mon mari excusez moi ça
m'en fais mes billets quand je parle de
lui depuis 44 ans nous allons avoir 45
ans de mariage dans deux mois mais la
vie d'un couple il ya des hauts des bas
je suppose que vous l'avez tous vécu
castaldi et puis tous bois comme on va
dire qu'à un moment donné on va dire
mettez la en veilleuse garçons on va
dire qu'à un moment donné mon époux a
été attirée après vingt ans de mariage
vert des chevelures vous élaborez des
saints qui tenait mieux des faits ce qui
a compté plus et paiera et voilà et je
me suis trouvé en état si vous voulez de
faiblesse très grande et à ce moment là
j'ai accepté une minuscule compensation
de films avaient laissé de mon frère et
ma soeur mais qui avait mis comme
condition que je ne rapatrie pas cet
argent en france parce qu'ils voulaient
plus rien avoir avec la france j'ai fait
une faute voilà donc elle mérite une
punition alors et nos missions
c'est incroyable c'est vous dire
qu'annie parce que non mais c'est vrai
qu'après après il ya plein de gens qui
sur les réseaux sociaux
ça n'excuse rien non non mais je ne
demande pas qu'on m'excuser et je ne
suis pas une victoire
voilà votre franchise et
vraiment je ne demande pas que l'on
m'excuser je ne demande pas que l'on
considère comme une victime
mon père j'ai m'avait appris que quand
on fait une faute il faut accepter la
sanction qui vient avec
donc je l'acceptent jeu les accepter
mais l'art aujourd'hui pour moi qui suis
une ancienne journaliste il ya deux
sanction la sanction pénale
d'accord et puis il ya la sanction
médiatique ça et celle là elle m'a fait
craquer clairement celle là elle est
très très très dur à vivre
qu'est-ce qui surtout que comme je
m'occupais de la com de la ville
voyez-vous mon petit fils m'appelle
mamiza geek et bah oui je suis j'ai fait
même beaucoup d'innovations dans ma
ville de levallois sur l'informatique et
donc je suis très informatisée
je suis très branché mais la belle quand
vous dites ce qui vous a le plus touché
on va passer à la dernière partie des
missions mais quand vous dites que vous
allez le le plus touché c'est les
répercussions médiatiques et ce qui
s'est passé autour de vous
médiatiquement vous allez nous expliquer
vraiment de quoi vous voulez parler
parce que c'est vrai que ça doit être
compliqué c'est compliqué on passa dans
la partie à l'isie puis on doit en
parler c'est con mercialys isabelle
c'est compliqué de se faire presser
d'escrocs de [ __ ] de voleuse de match
aller je vous en passe et des meilleures
c'est compliqué d'avoir des insultes
antisémites
parce que j'en ai eu ya il y en a eu des
centaines et des centaines
voilà ça c'est compliqué à vivre et
comment se faire une carapace
à un moment donné je suis parent idéal à
faire maintenant j'essaye de me la faire
mais ça c'est très très très dur
bon après voilà après j'ai mon âge
patrick a le sien
c'est vrai qu'on a eu des petits
problèmes de santé et mais voyez vous je
vais vous dire quelque chose
ce qui nous a le plus meurtri tous les
deux et surtout mon mari c'est cette
jurisprudence de l'inéligibilité
immédiate
nous avons consacré 35 ans à notre ville
nous avons voulu quelque part parce
qu'on a eu une enfance tous les deux
extrêmement aisé privilégiées nous avons
voulu quelque part rendre un peu de ce
qu'on nous avait donné on s'est consacré
nuitées jours à cette ville je pense que
patrick avait quelque chose de
formidable dans cette ville nous avons
mais au delà nous sommes arrivés à faire
une ville où toutes les communautés
vivent bien où les gens où il ya une
harmonie et que tout d'un coup
l'inégibilité immédiate qui est arrivé
en plus juste au moment du confinement
ça a été terrible pour nous alors
isabelle le 1er mai 2019
quelques jours avant l'ouverture de
votre procès ou publié un très long
texte sur facebook un texte terrible si
cette haine tout autour de vous dont
vous parliez il ya un instant qui vous
pousse à écrire ce message avec des mots
très forts notamment contre les
journalistes vous dites je suis fatigué
de voir certains décrivent un entre
guillemets au journaliste andré
guillemet sortir de leur hibernation
pour se repaître de leur détestation des
autres s'ériger en juge en moralisateur
en biens pensants se délectant se
délecter en pondant des sagas aussi
pitoyable que saugrenue et ravagé ainsi
des vies en provoquant des dégâts
affectif psychologique vous adresser
aussi à ceux qui vous aiment et vous ont
toujours soutenu je suis fatigué de
devoir dire et redire à celles et ceux
qui me font l'honneur de mémé notamment
dans ma famille levalloisienne pour
laquelle j'ai encore tant de choses à
réaliser que je suis bien celle que nous
sommes bien ce qu'ils connaissent et
apprécient loin des minables caricatures
qui en sont faites avec delek
délectation et vous finissez ce message
par une phrase terrible qui laisse
présager le pire
je suis fatigué et comme c'est la fête
du travail je vais en profiter pour
faire une grosse liasse de trois petits
points après ce message vous fait une
tentative de suicide en avalant une
forte quantité de médicaments isabelle
ça c'est un moment je vais vous dire
c'était ce qui m'a déclenché alors vous
allez dire que c'est complètement
peut-être anecdotique c'est lé faire mes
courses au supermarché
rien de plus banal et mais un monsieur
âgé tout d'un coup je connais pas du
tout
c'est la campagne puisque c'était le
week-end dernier j'étais d'accord qui
pousse son caddie vers moi qui étais
derrière mon caddie et qui me dit elle
put voleuse il m'insulte bon alors comme
ils étaient plus âgés que moi coup pour
lui j'ai pas réagi parce que je suis de
la génération savez monsieur ça vous à
ça vous a touché c'est ça qui a fait que
c'est quelque part ça a été la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase
voilà ajoutez à ça la fatigue les nuits
les nuits sans dormir
l'inquiétude pour patrick etc mais je
vais vous dire ce qu'ils vont sauver ce
sont des jeunes et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi est-ce que j'ai été
dans un hôpital qui soigne un we can ce
qu'on appelle un appui pas la suite de
votre tentative où et quand on m'a sauvé
quand le chu m'a sauvé j'ai été dans un
hôpital psychiatrique et les patients de
cet hôpital étaient des jeunes addict
je connais très bien le handicap je m'en
suis beaucoup occupé
j'ai par exemple les avs j'ai créé avec
l'actuel ministre il ya des années des
années mais je ne connaissais pas les
addictions et j'étais toute la journée
avec eux et finalement voyez vous il
faut s'occuper des autres pour pas
s'occuper de soi alors c'est idiot quand
c'est une phrase idiote que je vous dis
on vous disait vous ne regardez pas le
nombril mais c'est vrai c'est vrai mais
voilà ils m'ont sauvé je suis toujours
en contact avec eux et ils sont
formidables
bernard montiel oui isabelle vous parlez
beaucoup d habitants de levallois avez
vous le sentiment d'avoir trahi et voler
les habitants de levallois ses côtés
vous savez c'est toujours la même
histoire qu'est ce que c'est que
l'argent public l'argent public c'est
évidemment l'argent de l'état qui paye
avec la sécu ceci cela effectivement
quand vous
ne déclaraient pas toutes au fisc vous
quelque part l'appareil mais c'est pas
ce passage en bleu
l'amérique est à la mode c'est ce que je
voulais dire oui mais je tiens à dire
ses rides que les juges même ont tenu à
inscrire deux fois dans le jugement
alors ils l'ont inscrit avec les mots de
les mots je dirais un peu administratif
et techno c'est ils ont bien marqué
qu'il n'y avait pas un centime d'euros
d'argent public concerné voilà alors on
traduit évidemment on n'a pas piqué dans
la caisse de levallois pour être clair
nicolas pernikoff visuel vous êtes une
femme de communication redoutable et que
c'est quand même oui je pense que c'est
une des choses qui peuvent énerver
ils ont l'air provocante qui provoque
quand par exemple votre mari sort de
prison pour des raisons médicales et
qu'on le retrouve quelques semaines
après pour la fête de la musique en
train de danser ou de mettre une main un
peu baladeuses les deux les deux mon
capitaine
on va vous allez poser votre question
près parce que c'est une question que
d'isabelle qui revient à fond sur les
réseaux sociaux tout le monde pour cette
année à la lava attendait voilà donc ça
voilà c'était après
d'ailleurs il a beau kippa d'orge
il a manqué pendant
[Musique]
voilà alors allez-y nicolas parce que ça
tout le monde en parle oui alors il ya
ça je termine l'image du football là il
n'ya pas longtemps où il est en costume
sur son ligne dans un décor majestueux
avec à ce moment là vous faites un tweet
mais non mais qu'est ce que vous pouvez
comprendre que en fait toutes ces images
à un moment donné sont provocantes et
agace les gens je vous dis je peux le
comprendre mais je suis aussi étonné la
fête de la musique
on est à levallois ya le confinement
il n'y a pas de fête de la musique ils
ont organisé un camion qui qui circulent
dans la ville
on est avec des levalloisiens en train
de prod à prendre un pot dans un bistrot
bien tout le monde se lève pour danser
un petit coup parce que le camion s'est
arrêté
patrick je laime avec les autres parce
que patrick c'est un rocker parce que
c'est le meilleur ami de johnny et parce
que c'est comme ça et puis je veux quand
vous entendez de la musique vous vous
levez et moi aussi alors le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que vous avez
quelqu'un qui vous film oui mais bon un
autre connu et suivi à temps des
affaires balkany ouais vous êtes quand
même suivi mais ça fait vingt-quatre non
mais attendez formation on vous voit en
bout soit votre mari soumanou
storytelling qui est fait depuis des
semaines et des semaines et des semaines
il sort la première image qu'on voit de
lui quelqu'un qui est souffrant et qui
sort de prison parce qu'il est mal pris
mais d'accord il est au bord du gouffre
au bord de la mort ne gérait pas
nettoyer les informations qui sont
passés à l'époque oui souvenez que il
est à huit ans il a fait on a eu un
accident de santé qui est un accident
mortel dans la majorité des cas d'accord
mais là il sort vous êtes comme vous
n'ignorez pas les choses vous pensez
bien
ok vous êtes à levallois ya des gens qui
filme mais vous savez très bien à
l'extérieur qui a une image nationale
personnellement j'ai pas d'image
nationale on n'a jamais eu d'ambition
nationale ni l'un ni l'autre on alors
géraldine maillet alors moi je comprends
évidemment isabelle que ce soit très
violent quand quelqu'un vous insulte
comme ça dans le supermarché comme vous
l'avez dit mais comprenez aussi que pour
le citoyen mais où est il peut être
exaspéré mais je comprenais bien sûr
mais je le colle le grand politique
pourri le coach dans la marine auxonnais
mythique hors la loi non mais ça fait
partie aussi de de tout ça mais je le
comprends de la soie karadic et vous
avez tout à fait raison je ne suis
absolument pas dans le déni
vous l'avez compris très clair je
n'aurais du tout dans le béni voulez
savoir est-ce que vous regrets parce que
ces dernières années ont été
complètement gâchée
est-ce que vous avez un regret
aujourd'hui à mais j'ai un regret c'est
d'avoir fait cette faute stupide est
même pire que ça d'avoir cédé aux espèce
de chantage que m'ont fait que m'a fait
ma fratrie
mais je le regrette du fond du coeur
parce que j'ai pas été courageuse
voilà parce que je n'aurais pas dû le
faire mais bien sûr que je regrette
ça nous a gâché toute notre vie isabelle
isabelle je sais qu'on se connaît et je
connais patrick également de toute la
famille moi je sais que vous aimez les
gens je sais que c'est ce que vient de
dire géraldine elle a raison je la
rejoins c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de
gens qui vous aimait énormément qui
croyant vous qui se disait c'est les
gens qui nous font du bien dans notre
ville et vous avez déçu pas mal de gens
voient là et on le dit c'est vrai c'est
plus ça je pense qu'il vous qui voulez
aujourd'hui que c'est certainement moins
vrai dans notre ville mais que vous ne
le pensez c'est vrai à l'extérieur
justement voir des gens qu'ils ne
connaissent pas oui c'est ça alors que
dans notre ville je peux vous dire que
haute dose réduit comme hier nous sommes
chez nous nous nous y sommes souvent et
les gens sont adorables et d'ailleurs
pour tout vous dire nous vivrons
toujours à levallois puisque la mort
faisant partie de la vie nous y avons
nos tombeaux réservés
ah oui à levallois alors elle valoir
gilles heures il ya quelque chose qui
choque madame c'est ce sentiment d'une
justice à deux vitesses oui votre mari
vous avez été condamné pour fraude
fiscale blanchiment
car libéré pour raisons de santé puis
nicolas le disais on le voit danser vous
aurez bientôt un bracelet électronique
mais ça chemine éventuellement vers une
libération conditionnelle vous êtes vous
est pourvue en cassation on verra où ça
va mais on a l'impression quand même que
vous êtes des privilégiés de la justice
et je pense peut-être mais je vous
laisse répondre que ce traitement
n'aurait pas été offert à d'autres
justiciables que vous qu'est ce que vous
répondez à sa isabelle côté je réponds à
ça que ya ce que vous voyez ce qu'est ce
que vous voyez pas c'est à dire quand on
vous saisit tous que vous n'avez plus un
centime que ça a duré pendant des années
que si vous parlez d'un bracelet
électronique ce n'est pas un privilège
c'est simplement la nouvelle législation
qui tient compte du fait que nous avons
plus de 70 ans
et puis j'ai beau dire aussi même quand
vous êtes malade
même quand vous n'êtes pas bien en
l'occurrence mon mari après avoir été
magnifiquement soigné
d'abord avoir été sauvé par le personnel
pénitentiaire et je tiens à le dire
parce qu'ils sont souvent parce que
d'accord maintenant aujourd'hui tout le
monde juge tout le monde je voudrais
aussi qu'on me remette les choses en
place
est ce que le personnel pénitentiaire a
eu un réflexe absolument incroyable 1
puis par les médecins de cochin qui
l'ont soigné et qui l'ont sauvé de ce
fait je ne me rappelle plus du nom
scientifique mais ce qui est un
infarctus
interdigital qui est plus mortelle qu'un
infarctus du myocarde
voilà alors je veux déjà dire tout ça
bon je crois que nous ne sommes pas des
privilégiés
loin de là et puis alors vous savez
c'est ce que je vous disais aujourd'hui
ce qui est à la fois magique et
terrifiant danse me
c'est que tout le monde juge tout le
monde et qu'en plus on a sombré parce
que pour moi
l'ex soixante huitarde c'est sombre et
on a sombré dans une espèce de bien
pensants ce1 alors tout le monde juge
tout le monde mais là aussi il ya aussi
je ne me sens pas privilégier quand par
exemple je ne me sens pas privilégiée je
pense que je me
la condamnation mais je le veux le
répéter mais je ne me sens pas
privilégiée quand je vois par exemple
que la jeune femme qui a regardé son
enfant mourir
le petit tony pendant de cannes et 6 ans
pendant six jours d'affilée
son prétexte qu'elle était amoureuse de
son de jules elle à la même peine que
moi et bien là là je voulus oui c'est un
jugement personnel et je vous le dis je
trouve qu'il ya une semaine à bernard
dépôt d'accord non c'est pas pareil ça
isabelle pouvez pas comparer ces deux
cas la série assure que si non non pas
du tout pas du tout pas du tout imagine
ce que c'est que de laisser son mourir
son enfant mais décidemment mais c'est
pas comparable et 5,4 et ya quatre ans
de prison et indique géraldine bic vous
avait valeur d'exemple aussi mais est ce
que ne le pensez vous ne pensez pas que
les élus ont valeur d'exemple
qu'est ce que ça veut dire les élus ont
valeur d'exemple faisait toujours là
malgré l'image dans la nuit ils sont
élus démocratiquement
bah oui ils jugent ils il gère les élus
locaux que nous sommes nous ne sommes
pas des élus de premier plan
nous ne sommes pas des élus nationaux
mon mari a été député pendant 25 ans
mais bon on est surtout des élus locaux
on vous et lit on vous demande de
d'apporter quelque chose à vos
administrés si vous l'apporté il ya le
suffrage universel et vous êtes réélu jb
c'est une circonstance aggravante d'être
élu dans ces cas là parce que vous êtes
en responsabilité parce que vous avez
accepté
oui mais mais je suis d'accord avec vous
oui qu'est ce que je peux vous dire de
mieux que vous avez je ne vais pas vous
faire un acte de contrition jean vais
pas me couvrir la tête de cendres mais
je vous le dis j'ai fait une colossale
erreur et pire à mes yeux
à mes yeux pire j'ai manqué de courage
c'est à dire que je n'ai pas résisté à
cette proposition qu'on m'a faite
voilà c'est tout j aujourd'hui vous êtes
très actif sur les réseaux sociaux et
vous répondez à toutes les attaques qui
sont en bateau john rabe beaucoup aussi
sur la saint valentin est quelqu'un qui
vous avait attaqué en disant ah vous
êtes privilégiez vous pouvez pas céder
j'aurai alors qu'en fait tous les
habitants peut le faire donc c'est
souvent injustifiées ces attaques au
final ça vous fait marrer parce qu'elle
a dit qu'il était beau il est fébrile au
début au début ça me laissait m'a
blessée à un moment donné aujourd'hui je
me suis fait un petit carapace caserne à
isabelle on sait que vous êtes très aimé
que le président sarkozy est ce qu'il a
été embarrassé par votre affaire et
quelle fut sa réaction
vous savez l'amitié fraternelle parce
que ce n'est pas une amitié politique
nous connaissons nicolas sarkozy depuis
que nous sommes jeunes mariés nous
sommes connus à ce moment là et s'était
passé parce que j'appelle une amitié
politique
nous n'avons jamais demandé une
quelconque nomination à nicolas sarkozy
et il ne doit rien d'autre que d'avoir
été militant lors de ses campagnes
électorales
voilà donc c'est une amitié familiale et
je ne dis qu'il reste à vos côtés ce
qu'il reste à vos côtés mais bien
entendu ce que vous avez toujours
d'idées toujours reste à vos côtés
évidemment et vous resterez aussi un
élément oui c'est vrai oui c'est vrai
mais évidemment c'est ça l'amitié
vous savez en entrant de 50 gestion des
mairies
moi qui suis comme vous le constatez un
peu méditerranéenne extravertie qui met
volontiers vers les gens j'ai compris ce
que c'était que la véritable amitié et
les faux culs alors isabelle justement
des faux culs vous en a eu beaucoup
oh vous avez plus de faux cul que deux
combattants de quoi avoir un outillage
complet sur david villa valence avait
encore beaucoup d'amis où les normes
aimant vraiment encore énormément et
surtout est ce qui est magique
ce sont surtout les levalloisiens
anonyme
mais même ceux qu'on ne connaît pas tué
dans l'est mais dans les dents les
personnes connues voilà par nicolas
sarkozy ya d'autres gens vous
vraiment soutenu et qui en battant la
mythique où oui bon ça bon oui dans la
plaine oui bien sûr j'en connais il y en
a beaucoup qui ont quitté le navire qui
sont dit on veut plus leur parler parce
qu'on veut pas plutôt dans les élus
leval aux levalloisiens qu'il voulait
voilà que dans les landes elle dans les
amis extérieurs d'accord nicolas
isabelle vous êtes extrêmement populaire
à levallois perret est ce que vous
pensez un jour si vous êtes éligible aux
tournées sur une élection politique je
me dis dès les oublie
nicolas mais les abeilles très courte où
en êtes-vous financièrement ouais c'est
vrai bonne question d'isabelle vous
aurez tout financier remuons retraite
point barre tout le reste voilà windows
et une fourche une bonne question
d'isabelle mais c'est une bonne question
non mais je peux vous le dire je vais
vous dire une chose la retraite de
député parce que les députés cotisent
double et gagnent davantage en deux vous
amène à leur travail et davantage les on
va dire que les députés ont une bonne
retraite
les élus locaux mais c'est un scandale
parce que c'est déjà un scandale ce
qu'ils sont payés rémunéré 1 il faut le
dire les adjoints sont des mères elle
s'était reprise est pour vous très peu a
misérablement
c'est ingérable non mais arrêtez pas
lent par rapport à l'ensemble des
français au nom attendait chez vous je
vais vous dire en plus comment ces
calculs et celle ci a non mais t'es pas
d'accord mais je te le dis c'est pas
calculé par rapport au nombre
d'habitants et même quand c'est une
grosse ville levallois ya soixante six
mille habitants donc c'est une grosse
ville il ya une enveloppe et qui paye le
maire les adjoints et stop au départ à
levallois patrick avait toujours voulu
que donner une délégation aux
conseillers municipaux pour pas qu'il
soit simplement des chambres
d'enregistrement à ne rien faire au
conseil municipal donner une délégation
aux conseillers municipaux
rattaché à un hajj
et leur donner une indemnité donc on a
partagé la halle enveloppe entre tout le
monde entre les 45 et pas seulement la
majorité est bien un adjoint ce je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont à 1200 1300
euros
c'est la moyenne alors moi et c'est et
je peux vous dire que moi par exemple
c'était full time job c'est presque le
smic madame alors un adjoint au maire
d'arrondissement à paris ses 1100 euros
voilà c'est pas loin du smi
rihanna est alors beaucoup enfin je dis
bullet time job j'allais les gens qui
excusez moi isabelle la question de
nicolas pernikoff n'était pas
complètement stupide puisque le barça
non mais cyril l'attendait jamais remise
non mais le mal joué mais j'ai dit non
non le bâlois c'est le clan balkany est
ce qu éventuellement votre vous ne savez
rien dire ça c'est si c'est quand même
assez banal mais les gens ne le bâlois
vous adore donc est ce qu'il y aura une
signe à sion par exemple ou
éventuellement quelqu'un de votre
famille pourrait reprendre le flambeau
deux familles n'ont alors je vais vous
expliquer quelque chose sherman la
politique est devenue telle que je
connais peu d'enfants de politiques qui
aspirent à faire de la politique
en tout cas pas les miens juste deux
films alors votre vie elle a été fait
vraiment d'ambitions commune de
médiatisation est pouvoir donc je pense
ça vous a apporté beaucoup de
satisfactions mais aussi beaucoup de de
tourments de nuit blanche
oui si c'était à refaire est-ce que vous
choisissent est-ce que vous choisiriez
une vie plus humbles mais plus douces au
feu ted repas plus sains ne changeait
rien plus humbles ou pas que j'en sais
rien mais j'aurais choisi de continuer
dans le journalisme et la communication
ce qui m'aurait valu beaucoup moins non
mais en demandant les factures est bien
de le dire parce que j'aurais été de
l'autre côté de la barrière voyez vous
alors aujourd'hui il ya eu du nouveau on
l'a appris aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
votre condamnation pour fraude fiscale
vous allez être placé vous et votre mari
sous bracelet électronique
comment vous réagissez cette année au je
vous dirai simplement vous savez il ya
une chose que je ne supporte pas vous
j'espère que vous l'avez compris c'est
de juger les hauts de jugement je ne
supporte pas ça
et donc je vous dirai ça je ne répondrai
simplement vous d'exemple je suis pas
une femme à bijoux alors ça va me
changer
marcin c'est pas avant essais mais bon
la vie avec un bracelet électronique ça
ça va vous changer comme quelque chose
il avait tu sais quoi c'est quoi le
principe pour les téléspectateurs
alors le principe c'est que j'avais un
petit du mans en accord avec le juge
il y a des horaires où vous pouvez
sortir des horaires où vous devez rester
chez vous d'accord c'est il a fallu nous
manque six co logiquement ça ça vous
touche ou pas ça ou pas du tout à fait à
leur façon j'ai fait une connerie donc
vous vous dites c'est le prix à payer
voilà voilà bon voila j'ai un voilà
c'est la sanction quoi vous acceptez la
santé la sanction voilà non mais si vous
voulez juste voilà alors si vous
respectez vos engagements cette mesure
pourrait déboucher à terme sur une
libération conditionnelle
est ce que vous voyez le bout du tunnel
isabelle ou pas du tout ça avec un
tunnel il est pour moi un bon tout le
monde
oui mais voilà non mais vous savez voilà
je suis très très philosophe d'aqua gym
sauf que madame vous avez répondu à
énormément de choses mais voilà une
nouvelle affaire on a quand même un peu
l'impression avec vous qu'après les
affaires il ya toujours les affaires et
une nouvelle garde à vue
détournement de biens d'un dépôt public
abus de bien social encore une affaire
et à l'arrière des messieurs je ne veux
pas avec des mange le fera j'en parlais
madame je ne veux pas en parler parce
que l'instruction a oui cour a tardé
l'instruction est en cours
alors vous allez soi disant il ya le
secret de l'instruction
bien alors si vous savez il ya une
instruction c'est parce que ce secret
n'est plus respectée bien mais pas par
nous d'accord on est bien d'accord là
dessus
d'accord mais moi je respecte le secret
de l'instruction et je vois là c'est
tout et vous êtes sereine à mais tout à
fait moi je suis pas concerné de toute
façon mais je suis tout à fait sereine
d'accord sur ce dossier là vous êtes
soit mais complètement sur m il
s'appelle comment il va pas tribu
patrick va bien comment il a pris cette
décision aujourd'hui
alors il l'a prise avec philosophie va
mieux pour tout vous dire parce que là
encore je voudrais rendre hommage aux
médecins après deux ans d'horribles
souffrances du dos alors qu'il avait été
opéré d'une tumeur
la colonne vertébrale et qu'il a un
maillage un professeur fabuleux de
cochin a découvert qu'il avait une
maladie peu connue et depuis peu de
temps qu'il s'appelle la maladie
forestier qu'est ce que c'est votre
organisme fabrique de l'os plus qu'il ne
devrait pas ce que votre organisme
refabrique en permanence de lost mais la
ivè fait connaissez mon mari fait tout
avait été fait avec excès il fait de
plus de ce qu' il ne devrait en faire et
ça fait un bruit de madame da cau
minablement souffrir et comment ça va
tous les deux voulaient de tous les deux
sauber
mais comment d'ennui couple un bug là ça
va bien en ce moment ah oui mais ça va
mais bien sûr que ça va bien je sais
d'ores et déjà très bien mais comme tous
les couples et on s'engueule donc on
choisit les choses aillent a fait ça
bien sûr assez bien en fait je me
connais aussi
bah oui mais tu me connais aussi tu
deviens carrosse en gal forcément voilà
mais bon ça va qui s'engueulent bernard
qu'elle serait isabelle quelles seraient
les plus gros défauts de votre mari
parce qu'il est extrêmement jovial on le
connaît c'est une forme d'arrogance
peut-être qu'il a porté tort énormément
tout est à faire
maintenant il a absolument pas
l'arrogance dont sauf qu'il est comment
dire et que c'est même pas qu'il est
extraverti c'est qu'il est excessif
toujours dans ces cas précis et on parle
d'un défaut c'est le seul que je
pourrais y trouver c'est qu'il est
excessif et à tout va avec
s'ils me dit tu es toi mais comme il a
une grosse voix s'est pas mêlée ce que
je dirais terrible c'est une force
c'était une force de la nature et voilà
ça va avec et et je pense que ça fait
aussi partie de du fait que les gens
jouent à levallois l'aiment tellement
lui sur ton coup quand on veut re marche
et senna on est arrêté dans la rue
toutes les deux secondes
mais isabelle c'est quoi la suite
maintenant pour vous la vie ça va mieux
vous moi je vais mieux et ça allait
mieux parce que vraiment vous aider
voilà voilà
mais je vais vous dire j'ai une les
cécités absolue c'est de continuer à
faire marcher mes neurones la retraite
intellectuelle pour moi c'est
insupportable d'accord alors isabelle va
va être avec nous dans peut aller où
cette balance ton poste dans deux
semaines à valence ton post avec nous
pour agir sur le sujet de dans deux
semaines elle sera avec nous et isabelle
balkany au niveau de niveau de vos
regrets si vous aviez un regret ce
serait quoi vous us a le regret que j'ai
je puisse avoir c'est d'avoir par amour
uniquement parce que la politique
politicienne me gave et pas du tout mon
truc je suis pas manchot quand il faut
l'être moins sûr mais ça me gave j'ai
adoré le fait d'être une élue locale
parce que on construit on bâtit on a des
idées et j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
beaucoup d'idées qui d'ailleurs depuis
ont été reprises au plan national et
c'est notamment dans le domaine scolaire
les jeunes etc
mais c'est vrai que mon regret c'est
quelquefois quelque part d'avoir
abandonné le journaliste la com qui
était mon métier et de l'as bram i
simplement à la disposition de mon mari
et de la ville d'accord les voilà ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure que vous avez
dit on à fait j'ai fait une connerie
voilà il est aujourd'hui vous mais ça
c'était une connerie dans ma vie privée
personnelle
rien à voir avec mon rôle d'élu
c'était une connerie personnel pourra
l'utiliser jusqu'à parler de deux
jugements et il ya d'autres personnes
qui ont fait la fraude fiscale était
ministre du budget en chair de la fraude
fiscale qui ont pas et qui ont été
condamnés beaucoup moins lourdement donc
quand l'accès à deux vitesses moi je
trouve que pour le coup ils ont les
paris il parlait de lambda voilà et qui
surtout journal précise et non pas eu de
mandat de dépôt au tribunal immédiat à
71 ans merci isabelle balkany d'avoir
été avec nous en direct tiré il vous me
permettez 10 secondes sur allégis de
vous voyez on est moi tout sauf de
l'argent
[Rires]
non mais je voulais simplement je peux
te dire tu la juste mesure bah oui je
devrai simplement te remercier deux tons
et de thé courage ton courage de
l'amitié et ton courage de la liberté
d'expression de tous et en toute
occasion
si et ma conviction la plus profonde et
pour laquelle je milite depuis plus de
50 ans merci isabelle tu sais je vais te
dire je le disais lire je peux ne pas
être d'accord sur des décisions sur des
choses ou sur des faits qui ont été
faits mais l'amitié
quoi qu'il arrive on doit être là même
quand on n'est pas d'accord au canton
dames on n'est pas d'accord avec des
amis ou quand on est quand on les aime
en tout cas on doit être toujours là et
c'est vrai c'était pareil avec jean
marie bigard et à il ya deux jours qui
est venu s'exprimer
en tout cas merci d'avoir été là et
merci merci y aura